[Music]
who's going first I'm an FBI agent I'm
actually 43 years old I'm like
regretting choosing this secret cause
it's really embarrassing you're not
gonna like me after you know you shared
it you share the past with the person
that you're dating we've been like off
and on I guess oh my god will you pinky
swear promise that you'll like me after
that hold on I guess there was a woman
before my first girlfriend I never told
Mallory about so I'm one of our off
periods I don't want to know there was a
thing with someone we both know
I got dared for the rest of freshman
year any time that you clip your
fingernails or toenails put them in a
mason jar and it like became a thing
like we're four years of college it was
like a large joke and I kept doing it I
don't hate you but yeah that's straight
of gross you do not have it that was my
first sexual occurrence was a Fisker
hell and we still communicate pop and on
it's like a mentor-mentee kind of thing
why are you the grossest thing
everywhere are you crying
who was it um someone whose hair colors
now similar to mine I know we're going
to San Francisco this week and she's up
there and I was really thinking about it
did I have to do it for four years now
and we all like said like at the end
like whoever first gets married like in
our friend group like that's their
wedding yeah they're like brown she sort
of like sight looks like you've been oh
I always thought the dynamic was so good
now I know why where do you keep it I'm
bad
that's even worse that's like Disturbia
I know but that's you know I'm glad you
told me that there's more my god is that
the whole thing
thank God your beauty could have thought
of a better one I guess yeah that was
way yeah she was straight-up crying my
eyes teared up oh my gosh
what that was so weird I just didn't you
knew about this I'm kind of disappointed
in your I know your imagination that's a
show your acting chops
[Music]
yeah I'm disappointed
thanks guy good hit a different
boyfriend
stay tuned you date toenail girl huh
yeah she's pretty but she's crazy for
keeping toenails yeah I know
I just found out the same thing you did